hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
now yeah I didn't stop I couldn't stop I
literally could not walk away from this
knowing what happened to the last the
last group of people that I was with it
was heartbreaking seeing every one of
those people that I've been watching
since the beginning and trying to help
and I came so close I came so far I
learned so much and I came so close and
I just didn't get there I was that close
yeah probably not I was probably miles
away
probably they probably would have died
for another reason if it wasn't gonna be
food but it just I couldn't leave it at
that so what I'm gonna do is I'm coming
back into it I'm gonna start a new one
and I am gonna go for this because I am
ready so what I want I don't want anyone
who is a destructive [ __ ] I want
vomitus because at least vomiting
doesn't break your [ __ ] so I'm gonna pay
attention to that huh all right this is
good yeah I can do better than that
ahh gasp your phobia can't cook yeah we
can do better
scaredy-cat can't fight that's okay
night ow the not-so underground fortress
starving space pad that strikes a chord
with me the starving space pad will be
the most food abundant space pad in the
entire universe I don't even know where
this is in relation to the entire but
I'm hoping that's gonna be okay alright
so first off new hope yeah you got a new
hope alright you're cruel could be best
to start digging oh yeah it is okay so
everybody just hold onto your horses
here because I'm gonna go through this
very methodically so as we see above us
we got Aqsa light which is providing a
lot of oxygen obviously so we're gonna
keep that around we've got water right
there we've got very adjacent water
source
that's actually quite good meal wood
there which is fine all right so the
first step of what we're doing we
already have food I don't need to worry
about that for a good long time so what
we're gonna do is I'm gonna dig over to
here hmm I'm not gonna quite break that
wall just yet but I know we can dig that
high and then we're gonna bring it to
this wall here just in case it decides
to break on us all right go for it
when you don't have too many problems
things seem to go a little easier for
you oh yeah oh now we're getting it oh
man I got a research everything all over
again that was one of the benefits is I
got all my research out of the way first
before but this time this time I'm gonna
go I'm gonna do it we're gonna do it
right I'm gonna do it well Oh things run
so smoothly now the bits is lovely
I can't believe it I can hardly believe
it oh no nails is stress so what are we
gonna do about that oh no stress not
that okay the other thing that it was a
problem in the last game that I did is I
built too much and too much his uh is
just as bad as not enough in my opinion
anyway
oh good three beds right there that'll
be perfect going to going to eat going
to eat perfect oh you just [ __ ] yourself
god damn it we just frickin did this
[ __ ] research station come on come on
whoo we're about to get our next
duplicant so the benefit of what we have
here is actually there are meal wood
plants up here it's nice and cool up
there it works out well they're doing
their thing everything is good but we
will need to worry about oxygen very
soon so I'm gonna need them to dig out
basically this stuff here and then I'm
gonna put a hold on this stuff because
we don't need it immediately there's not
an express concern of ours
so we're gonna have this one we got
research farming tech that's what we're
gonna need we're gonna need farming
Tecmo Stefan Italy and then everything
else can wait until we got farming tech
underway so once that gets powered which
it is now we're gonna have this just
generate a novice research out the wazoo
until we're good to go
so this is fine you see how planning
makes things go much easier wouldn't
who'da thunk it man this is crazy
oh man coordination equals cooperation
equals love I love it oh whoa what the
hell god damn it how did that just bury
through that many oh you gotta be
kidding me oh come on
oh Jesus of course if it's not one thing
it's another thing well I guess there
goes my water [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] are
you joking thank you god dammit of
course
oh god they're all flooded now freaking
wonderful frickin frickin wonderful if
it's not one thing it's another all
right any day now on those microbe
crushers that'd be nice okay they're
gonna eat they're gonna eat they're
gonna eat they're gonna eat a whole lot
we get the algae terrariums going their
way which is good totally fine they're
gonna use some water that's again
totally fine and then eventually we just
need to focus on getting more all right
so we now have these so we're gonna use
these to make lice loaf only that way we
don't have anyone doing a mush bar and
they're not getting very you know sick
so now that we got that I'm gonna hold
off on the research for now because I
need to make I need to make a refinement
thing which is a composter right here
cuz we're gonna need that yeah because
we can't just have contaminated dirts
sticking around cuz that's gonna be bad
for everybody let's make this a priority
building all right so now that this is
open here we can put some farming tech
here some planter boxes
just a whole boatload of them we're not
gonna run out of food this time not
today not today not today we're gonna
put these there we're gonna get this
just unbelievable amounts of meal wood
okay so far so good everything seems to
be looking up there is a puffed right
over here that is in a nice sustainable
place so if I can seal that off
keep that puff doing what that puff does
I'll create a double air lock so
absolutely no contaminated of oxygen
gets in our way and then should be good
be good oh we got a new person come on
in all right
uh-oh all of them are destructive good I
guess
we're just gonna always get destructive
okay irritable bowel burning Gus Sybil
and a farters let's get Vernon in here
he doesn't need much to be satisfied
come on Vern and we got work to do and
preferably not death to do looks like
this might actually be producing some
contaminated oxygen which I didn't think
it was actually doing but it seems like
it is so I'm not gonna let that get to
me it's definitely not gonna happen so I
got a really think about this I've got a
really really think about the layout
because what I've created here is a
place where every gas can flow between
one and the other so contaminated oxygen
is going to affect everything around it
I don't think these terrariums are gonna
be enough to get through but they use so
little like little hey you so little
algae but the problem is I don't know if
it's like this just does a faster or
what yeah this uses ten this uses a
kilogram of algae per second okay so
that's not an equivalent exchange the
better option is algae terrarium like
that just is what it is I'll move them
if need
but I just like because that's a
one-to-one ratio it consumes 1 gram of
algae per second to emit a certain
amount of oxygen per second sometimes
more than the gram of algae but the
algae deoxidizer takes more algae than
it puts out oxygen so there's no reason
to use that in my opinion right now
maybe in the future yes but in my
opinion right now I think it's more
beneficial to use the algae terrariums
and just have more of them now the
problem is they will use water and water
is a finite resources and it does use
quite a bit of water so there's that
exchange it's really fascinating how
it's so hard to find a point of
equilibrium in this game like you're
always pushing to do like a little more
you have to keep going or else you're
gonna die like that's always a constant
threat in this game and I really like
the challenge because you can never just
sit and go like ok I've got this is all
good that's good I like this we're all
done here and I'm happy that's not the
way it goes you just constantly always
are pushing a little harder because
they're always consuming oxygen they're
always consuming food they're always
dying for one reason or another they're
always stressed for one reason or
another
we'll get there though you will get
there
so what I need to do is I need to start
planning my filtration stuff cuz the
research is almost done on the
supercomputer it'll be there probably
before the end of today then I need to
start building the two stage filtration
center for like the dump of all the the
dump for the other stuff and then you
know yada yada yada
okay stress is down stress is at zero
yes we're keeping stress down okay
that's good so we've got tons and tons
of algae
all over the place and oxalate but
that's got a good bit of oxygen up there
Oh what I'll Vernon goddammit mop that
up
dammit Vernon the bathroom is right
there Oh needs to be hoops oopsies oopsy
poopsy is indeed so I've got the liquid
step oh we got harvest time baby oh we
got harvest time do I have a
refrigerator yet no I do not fine dining
research but that's coming next after
sanitation oh [ __ ] yeah but I think
that'll be okay with that cuz that's
gonna be enough to oh yes oh yes give us
all give us all that oh hell yes make
all the meal lights low fluff least
labeled low fleiss's leaf leases okay
there we go
cool so now the water is gonna be kind
of oh well Gabrielle you done you done
[ __ ] yourself now all right how about
you try to try to get out over there
first
yeah go for Gabrielle sorry you were
stuck Oh someone Vernon why are you
stressed Vernon Oh cuz you're literally
in the [ __ ] there okay so what we're
gonna need
because we need to run number one run
power through the floor here arms gonna
run through the floor I was gonna fall
on here and then we're gonna build a
water pump down here click a bomb right
at the base in there probably and yeah
brothers good we're gonna liquid pipe so
that's pumping out so that needs to pump
into the end of this so I need to have a
liquid bridge of some sort
liquid pipe bridge and then this can go
underneath it yeah yeah that's how you
do it okay and then the out is we're
contaminated water is so then that can
run that can okay that could run over
there to that pool but I'll need to be
careful about that because it's gonna be
that's gonna again that's gonna be
contaminated area so I need to build an
airlock a tile okay so I just like the
double airlock you know idea just so it
makes sure that no contaminated oxygen
can slip through yeah tons and tons of
oxygen in here this is pretty much
saturated with oxygen we've got a good
bit of algae left so we're going good
there were running we ran out of our
first source of water I want to make
sure we don't run out of this one too
I'll try to make an exchange here as
well but I don't see a puffed but we'll
get there when we get there once again
there won't this is list all this water
is literally just for showering and
sanitation purposes only and once again
it's just Vernon that seems to be
stressed more than anybody else all
right so that's mostly done so this just
needs power now so once this goes it
should go and then these should be
running correct
and then we'll have no they won't
because then they don't have an outpour
and yet but they will
so what we're gonna do is after this
we're gonna build a ladder down and then
it's just going to be piping they're
there and they're there and then it's
just gonna literally fall right okay and
then that should be all that is needed
okay I'm actually kind of worried
because things seem to be going pretty
well for me and they don't usually do
that when I'm playing this game so I'm a
little bit cautious so what's going on
here I just don't want to be too eager
about nothing until I get to where I
need to get holy [ __ ] it worked oh my
god but not yet because they got to get
the outflows too but oh man that works
holy [ __ ] yeah I just I don't want to
back up - could be in there [ __ ] okay
keep building that stop letting so much
contaminated oxygen in okay can you not
do that the double airlock was supposed
to prevent that thank you very much okay
you don't need to go through there
anymore in fact I might make that other
door yeah I'm actually gonna do this
we're gonna build this and we're just
gonna get rid of that one but not until
we built that one now until we build
that one do you get rid of that one just
make it farther away from each other all
right whatever I guess we're gonna have
a leak no build her airlock goddamn it
you sons of [ __ ] his sons of [ __ ]
causing problems for me so what you
doing come from huh gonna be like that
okay
stress is way down stresses wave Vernon
is still a little stressed I don't know
maybe he's just a whiny baby but stress
seems to be way down and I'm pretty
happy about that I'm also pretty happy
of the way this is going and you may
have noticed that I've been a little
hesitant to go meet the people that are
part of this but I just don't want to
lose again
you know I don't want to feel like I
feel like you're gone so just let him
hold him Adam arm's length until I feel
honored ooh
ready for harvest hell yeah buried
mockery
harvest that [ __ ] okay so we're gonna go
over there mmm jobs oh they can have oh
they can have specialized jobs oh I
didn't know that oh well I don't have
anything that I wanted them to do just
right away but I'm just gonna oh I could
definitely specialize him later God
definitely I could [ __ ] yeah
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to we're gonna we're gonna build oh we
don't have the extra power research
that's right okay so as soon as fine
dining is done we're gonna do more yada
yada yada
I mean this is fine for what it is the
pump isn't going all the time so seems
to be doing just fine
okay research complete oh I thought that
was the sound of the research being done
supercomputer go go supercomputer go uh
Tibet a dog all supercomputer
supercomputer could you go please
still don't know if that's enough space
in between the two of them but I'm gonna
I'm just gonna I'm gonna risk it I'm a
risk it okay baby that was the sound of
it okay so we need to make a
refrigerator what we need to do for the
food storage so we're gonna make a
refrigerator up here cuz I wanted to run
power up here anyway
cuz I'm gonna make this the mess hall
just something nice for them to have and
enjoy yeah yeah cuz now they've gone in
the furniture Department the oh they
don't oh we need interior decor Oh fine
then ooh insulated tiles but I need
temperature regulation to do that hmm I
could do I could use the last simple one
I'll do that okay
we'll just have that up there we'll
eventually have more but just for now
that's where that will be
yep is that a newbie there might be a
newbie newbie come on in come on in boo
boo
all right grease monkey and mole hands
nice narcoleptic Bertrand all
destructive Oh take this one
Bertrand come on in Bertrand love you
Bubba are you doing great you're doing
great you're all doing great we've got a
lot of food actually we've got a whole
hell of a lot of food lots of life
slopes I would rather have them in the
refrigerator but I think it's okay okay
this is where things are gonna get a
little bit dicey we need to do quite a
few things before we can continue on cuz
every single time I approach this slime
I have to be mindful of the contaminated
oxygen and the contaminated water so
even before I go in there and do this
stuff I need to have a system set up to
gather slime and contain it because what
I want to do is I want to make a water
filter to put this stuff and and bring
it into here so that we can have
purified water coming in here which is
fine because that's good but in order to
do that we have to have a better system
suffocate whoa who's suffocating who's
suffocating who the hell is suffocating
oh my god Brady what the [ __ ] happened
to you god damn it Brady what the [ __ ]
someone save him now are you kidding me
is that what the sound I was hearing was
somebody save him
destructed a priority of nine god damn
it
Oh No Brady Brady oh my god Brady Jesus
Christ what happened what the [ __ ]
happened to you oh boy yeah I didn't
plan that correctly okay all right then
well we got a lot of contaminated
contaminated oxygen leakage there but
holy [ __ ] then okay so what I've done is
a little bit complicated admittedly I've
created a way to have this
water purifier down here they'll dig out
through this ladder to get down here
they'll build a wall around here the
pipe will go around it blah blah blah so
it looks complicated it's not really
they just got to do it and hopefully not
too much contaminated oxygen gets
through this so I'm pretty sure this is
good so I'm just gonna let this go and
have them all do it it doesn't really
matter the order because it's all
contained over there and then the slime
is ready for their just in case they get
it or any of that or whatever have you
and then what I could do is if I have a
purifier here and air deodorizer I can
put this right here to remove
contaminated oxygen from this zone here
I'd probably be better off having it
over here considering it needs it
doesn't need power and then that needs
oxygen anyway it looks like I need to
get rid of some carbon dioxide here so
weirdly enough I think I need an algae
and algae terrarium I think up time for
bed nevermind you'll do that tomorrow so
hold on I still got a lot of work to do
but we'll get there in shorts Bertrand
that is a bad place to sleep that is
like the worst place you could possibly
have decided to sleep I applaud your
tenacity but you're extremely foolish
alright good luck
stress is gonna rise from this a little
bit but I hope it's gonna be okay over
time and I put this here because this is
gonna be the beginning of another slime
refinement because if there's slime
refinement right here which might
actually be better than that over there
I can drop right into my already
pre-made filtration system and then
eventually I'm gonna cut over here did
we get a top-priority dig to get these
together please thank you oh look at him
go they're so studious when you got a
plan things work out things work out so
good things work out so good man I've
I've been I've been doing this for an
hour and a half now I can't even I don't
even think I've been playing that long
just because that's how much fun I've
been playing I've been recording this
for an hour and half I just realized
that holy [ __ ]
I should probably put this
to a stop for now so I'm gonna end this
here I've been having a crazy amount of
fun with this one this is probably the
last one that I'm gonna record for today
just because I'd just be playing it for
hours and hours if I didn't but I'm back
I think I've got a good strategy I think
I know where to go with this so I'm
gonna keep hitting it in the next
episode yes a monkey plan because I
freaking love this game so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye
[Music]